[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
du théâtre de la ville de mario paul il
ne reste que des décombres le théâtre a
été détruit par une frappe russe comme
les habitants qui ont quitté la ville
m'ont dit qu'ils ont eu beaucoup de
chance de ne pas se trouver dans ce
théâtre malheureusement tout le monde
n'a pas eu cette chance c'est vraiment
un génocide de la nation ukrainienne des
centaines de personnes s'y cacher le
bâtiment est détruit et le bilan inconnu
j'ai le coeur brisé par les actes de la
russie contre mon peuple nous n'avons
pour l'instant aucune information qui
permettent d'établir un bilan si ce
n'est celle ci qui émane de la porte
parole du président hélène ski
l'abri anti bombes a tenu la majorité
des personnes est en vie les gens
sortent des décombres
le peuple russe s'il sera toujours
distinguer les vrais patriotes de la
racaille et des traîtres ils vont juste
les recracher de vue comme une mouche
qui accidentellement voler dans leur
bouche ils vont juste les recracher sur
le trottoir je suis convaincu qu'une
telle autorisation de naturel et le
nécessaire que la cheville rixe ne fera
que renforcer notre pays
faut-il qu'un président celui des
états-unis
rentrer dans
cette façon de dire et et de parler est
ce que c'est son rôle pour être franc
avec vous je ne le crois pas
de 4h pour dévoiler une trentaine de
propositions et sans surprise emmanuel
macron érige le travail comme priorité
nous devons travailler plus
je ne suis pas un donneur de leçons je
suis d'anti patrick cohen voilà qui est
un donneur de leçon je l'aimé encore ce
matin donner des leçons sur mon émission
il sas les gens ne veulent plus de ça
voilà on est comme une batterie cohen il
est très gentil mais il est chez de vie
sains il est tranquille dans son petit
appartement du du 6e arrondissement je
sais pas où tu habites mais bon voilà on
y va tous les soirs poser son cul sur la
chaise de c'est à vous pour dire de
mouiller pour prendre installer un mot
qui doit être assez confortable autre
annonce au l'emploi deviendrai est un
guichet unique rebaptisé france travail
espère mais donner des notions qu'on
sait il faut pas voter pour untel il
faut voter pour untel faut pas dire ça
peut pas regarder ça patrick cohen il
serait mieux de balayer devant sa porte
et d'arrêter de donner des conseils aux
français pour 40 minutes 45 minutes pas
beaucoup non moi je suis un sportif très
tranquille après une vague
d'encouragement et de multiples messages
de soutien le candidat poursuit sa
campagne malgré selon ses mots un
contexte inimaginable et un président de
la république qui a lui-même peur de son
ombre avec ses salariés qui défilent
aujourd'hui du privé comme du public je
réclame une hausse des salaires et des
retraites c'est urgentissime le smic à
1900 euros brut il va être
automatiquement revalorisé sans doute
avant l'été et pour un montant de
l'ordre de 25 euros net pour un salarié
au niveau du smic je peux pas être plus
précis parce que fabien roussel a
commencé le sport très tôt avec de la
gymnastique pendant six ans dont il
garde quelques compétences
bien tous propose de revaloriser le smic
et en la matière la plus généreuse c'est
nathalie arthaud qui veut porter le smic
à 2000 euros nets là nous avons la
possibilité sur la base des résultats
que nous avons obtenus pendant le
quinquennat on parle pas en l'air nous
avons des résultats sur l'emploi
d'arriver d'ici 2022 à 5% de taux de
chômage vous posez
je crois que je m'en fous un peu si
pendant la campagne tous les coups sont
permis valérie pécresse séparer elle a
pratiqué la boxe pendant cinq ans avant
de se mettre au yoga